I think only half the the the 12 billion
arms shipped in the last year went into
mobile phones so that means 6 billion
went somewhere else
a few have gone in raspberry pi's yes
but they're also in you know the the DSL
Wi-Fi base stations you have in your
house and they may I don't know if
they're in that camera and they're there
they're all over the place at the time
we embarked on the arm design there
wasn't a single dominant micro processor
company in the way that on the desktop
Intel is dominant today and of course in
the mobile embedded arm is equally
dominant but at that time there were a
number of companies and there was quite
a lot of creativity in the
microprocessor market it seemed like
there were more opportunities for new
companies but really at acorn we just
wanted something that works in our
desktop machines we were designing a
processor for acorns products and we
went into this quite tentatively and and
very unsure that we'd come out with
anything that ever got used
we had formed the firm view that the
primary determinant of a computer's
performance is is the memory bandwidth
you can access to the processor
notionally the thirstier 16 has a nice
instruction set in the 6502 as a
primitive one but if you looked at the
performance you got it just scaled with
the bandwidth the 16-bit microprocessor
could not use the bandwidth that was
available in the memory that people put
in these machines so you spent your
money you bought some bandwidth and then
you were coupling this to a processor
that couldn't use that basic resource
and this just struck us as wrong and we
were wondering what to do about it we
were just sort of dithering basically
when Herrmann dropped on our desks
copies of some papers from particularly
from Berkeley but also from Stanford
that described a different sort of
processor designed by student classes
this was of course risk reduced
instruction set computing the standard
processes of the time were what was then
called kiss
complex instruction set computers they
would have you know instruction sets
similar to the digital VAX which had you
know a single instruction for subroutine
entry which did all sorts of stuff and
didn't match that many languages so lots
of languages had to do subroutine call
by different means because the
instruction wasn't just right while the
industry was moving one way the RISC
idea was to go the other way and Roger
started sketching out risk like
instruction set designs and and the the
real turning point was they were doing
this during the summer of 83 the real
turning point was about October 83 when
the two of us went out to Phoenix
Arizona to look at a company that was
building an evolution of the 6502 to
give it to 24-bit address space instead
of the 16-bit on the BBC micro
this was the 65 ca-16 I think and we
went to Phoenix expecting to find you a
big American company with large shiny
office blockin lots of expensive
equipment what we discovered was this
design work was going on in a bungalow
in the suburbs and they were hiring vac
students to do cell design on Apple 2
computers and so on and it was it really
sort of felt more like a cottage
industry than a big American enterprise
and so we came away from there thinking
well if they can design a microprocessor
maybe we can that was late 83 and as we
set about designing the arm we didn't
really expect to pull it off okay
firstly we thought this RISC idea is so
obvious the big industry will pick up on
it and we'll get trampled underfoot
secondly we still had this slight queasy
feeling that microprocessor design was a
black art and at some point we discover
why this was a really bad idea to be
doing ourselves Roger had a very firm
idea of what he wanted from an
instruction set because he written all
these basic interpreters into a new
about of the high level languages as
well and the the interesting thing
alongside this is that
I think Andy hoppers influence Herman
had decided that in the future there
were only going to be two sorts of
computer companies those that had
learned to design on silicon and those
are the gone bust
and so acorn was going to be in the
first category so we'd gone we look
around the world for tools for designing
chips we identified tools from VLSI
technology in San Jose
we bought workstations which then were
very expensive
Apollo workstations for these tools to
run on and we'd gone out and hired chip
designers when we had a chip design
group who didn't have much to do so this
was the strategy that that said we have
to be able to do this but haven't quite
worked out why yet and so as we were
sketching a microprocessor design we had
these chip designers who were ready just
to take the ideas and map them onto
silicon most of that work happened in 84
we taped out in January 85 historically
you design the chip on a computer so you
build all the files you needed to make
the chip on a computer and then because
this was a large data structure you
write it all onto a tape and then you
put the tape in the post to the fab and
shipping the tape is the crunch point
okay up to that point you can change
things once the tapes gone it's gone and
so even today we still talk about tape
out even though no physical tape is
injured in the course of making chips
anymore everything's done over the
internet that we still call it tape out
when you finally push the button and say
we can't think of anything else to test
let's make it but in 85 when we were
doing this for the arm an acorn we
didn't have the tools to do the final
checks on the design so we took the
design probably on physical magnetic
tape to Munich to VLSI technologies
offices and use their equipment and
their tools to do the final tests and
then said go make it and it was a
spectacularly cold winter I remember
walking around Munich where most of the
taxis were lying dead by the side of the
road because their fuel had frozen
in in the pipes and this is diesel fuel
and getting the taxi so it was really
cold but that was the tape out and then
you go home and wait and typically the
processes take about three months they
have to make masks for doing the various
layers and at the end of it they produce
wafers which they then have to break up
and package and then they send you the
package parts now the thing you do in
three months of course is you build the
circuit board because when the chip
arrives you want to plug it in see if it
works and crack the champagne a
tradition that's I think probably
started a bit before the arm that
certainly if you go to arms offices in
Cambridge you'll find there's a war with
hundreds of champagne bottles a fitted
sir I'm sure Herrmann started this
tradition at acorn and I do it here in
Manchester as well when we get to cheer
back when it works it has to work it
doesn't have to be tested very
extensively this has to sit in the board
and and you know play ball for a few
seconds and then you've opened the
champagne I don't remember what program
we used initially it will probably be
some very simple hello world but very
quickly we got BBC basic hub if it run
basic then it was pretty much working
okay the basic would test most features
of the chip was it's a frog we expected
to go into this project finding out why
it wasn't a good idea to do it and and
the and the obstacle just never emerged
from the mist we just kept moving
forward through the fog until eventually
we had a fully working ARM chip in our
hands and and it did what we expected it
it gave about twenty five times the
performance of the BBC micro which is
exactly what the memory bandwidth
calculations predicted it worked it was
cheap it was low-power I don't think he
was day one but a few days later we
decided we better measure the power
consumption so I set up a circuit board
with an ammeter in series with the power
supply and just the power supply to the
ARM chip itself turned the ARM chip in
turn the ARM chip on run some and some
code on it looked at the ammeter and it
was reading zero
I knew we designed a fairly low power
but this was a bit remarkable and it
turned out that actually had in
inserting the ammeter into the power
supply I'd failed to connect the power
supply so no current was flowing through
the ammeter that the chip was still
running we had to think about this for a
bit because this is what usually
happened so so hang on so it wasn't just
you didn't connect the ammeter it was
actually that you didn't connect the
chip to the power supply
yes there was no power supply connection
to the chip yes and Yeti was running and
what of course was happening when you
thought about it it was fairly clear is
there were external chips providing
inputs and the inputs to a CMOS circuit
have protection diodes which basically a
desert there to stop the input going
outside the rails and burning
transistors out but in this case what
they were doing was feeding power from
these input signals into the power
supply and powering the whole chip so so
effectively we were powering the chip
from the signal inputs and we connected
the ammeter properly and measured the
power and indeed it was very low as it
would have to be to be powered from the
single inputs but it was finite the low
power properties of the arm are are a
key to its longer-term success they were
not actually crucial to a cons
application our requirement was that
this should go in the desktop machine so
there was a tethered power supply but it
should go in a plastic package because
plastic packages cost a few tens of
cents and ceramic packages cost tens of
dollars and to go in a plastic package
you had to come in under a watt what's
about the limit today it's probably
about two watts but in order to get it
under a watt we had to be careful with
the engineering and the tools were not
very accurate so we we effectively
applied Victorian engineering margins to
the power and it actually came in under
a tenth of what later on that low power
characteristic became one of the key
selling features
the low-power is very closely related to
the complexity of the design I mean arm
is an incredibly simple processor at
least it was in 1985 and some variants
of the armor now not quite so simple but
it used twenty five thousand transistors
to what order of difference was that I
should know the number but I'm afraid I
don't remember and I do remember that
arm was was fewer and the small number
of transistors meant there's less
switching activity in every clock cycle
and therefore less power so there was no
magic to its low power characteristics
apart from simplicity so how does that
feel then to know that you are part of
the beginning of something so big I mean
I am staggered by the success of arm I
mean the success of arm very much
underpins my reputation okay which I
sometimes feel a bit guilty about
because although I certainly played a
role in sowing the seeds you know it's
taken thousands of people a lot of
effort since then in certain some of the
time I think you know the three and
three point three thousand people
working for armor or just working to
enhance my reputation but it is an
effect of what they do
which I don't feel is fully earned these
days it's 25 years since I yesterday
it's very much since since I left that
it's a you know it's a great company and
of course it you know it's been there
throughout my subsequent professional
career and and all my researchers had
some kind of link to arm and so long
they live absolutely it's a great
success and if you know the person that
runs on the CEO of arm today you'll see
he's master's thesis on my shelf over
there so
I did a lot of my own soldiering yes and
the computer stuff was all built with
Vera wah which was a fairly standard
technology this is one hundred thousand
processor spinnaker machine it has five
of the card frames that we saw in the
previous shot